With half-finished visual effects
and a stunted production schedule,
even a Sith Lord couldn't revive "Mortal
Kombat: Annihilation" in the eyes of moviegoers.
After making a splash in the 1995 "Mortal Kombat,"
film Linden Ashby and Christopher Lambert both
declined to return for "Annihilation," and
were each recast with different actors.
In an interview featured in the 2017 book
"Lights, Camera, Game Over!," chronicling
the movie's production, producer Lawrence
Kasanoff attributes a scheduling conflict
to Lambert dropping out from "Annihilation."
Years after the 1997 film's release, however,
Lambert cited the poor quality of the
script for his decision to not return.
"Ha Ha Ha! … Sorry."
Kasanoff also claimed that Johnny Cage was killed
early in "Annihilation" to shock the audience,
but Ashby disputes this. In a
separate interview in "Lights,
Camera, Game Over!," Ashby claims he was
open to reprising his role as Johnny,
but Kasanoff did not want to honor his
sequel deal. After seeing the script for
"Annihilation," Ashby also turned down the
offer due to the poor quality of writing.
Johnny Cage wasn't the only returning fighter
recast for "Annihilation," as J.J. Perry replaced
Chris Casamassa as Scorpion when Casamassa signed
on to do stunts in "Batman & Robin" instead. More
than just playing the yellow-clad ninja warrior,
Perry also played Noob Saibot and Cyrax in the
film, with each ninja getting their own fights
in the movie. Pulling triple duty came at a
painful price for Perry, as the actor and stunt
performer injured himself during production.
Perry revealed that the cumbersome mask involved
in the Cyrax costume inhibited his vision,
causing Perry to roll his ankle on a power
cable. Because of this injury, Perry says
he wasn't at his full physical potential for
Scorpion's fight scene against his icy rival,
Sub-Zero. In a 2019 interview with
Upcomer.com, Casamassa revealed that
the planned fight sequence between Scorpion
and Sub-Zero had originally been designed to
be longer and more ambitious, but may have
been shortened after his role was recast.
It wasn't only major cast members who were
replaced from the original "Mortal Kombat."
Its director, controversial filmmaker Paul W.S.
Anderson ultimately opted not to helm the sequel.
Anderson made a name for himself in the late
'90s and early 2000s overseeing films that
were often financially successful, such as
genre fare like "Alien vs. Predator." His
decision not to return to "Annihilation"
opened up the director's chair to John
R. Leonetti, the cinematographer
from the first "Mortal Kombat."
Though Anderson maintains his vocal respect
for Kasanoff, in an interview in "Lights,
Camera, Game Over!," he described his dynamic with
the producer as less than smooth during
"Mortal Kombat"'s production. However,
he voiced his support in having Leonetti
promoted to director for "Annihilation."
Whereas the 1995 "Mortal Kombat" was
filmed in California and Thailand,
"Annihilation" was more ambitious, with
production traveling to a higher number of
countries for filming locations during principal
photography. In a 1997 interview with GamePro,
Lawrence Kasanoff promised the film would be
bigger in scope and action than its predecessor.
This meant there would be more scenes set
within the parallel universe of Outworld,
filmed in more exotic locations to create an
otherworldly aesthetic to the proceedings.
"Your planet and our world have begun to merge
into one realm. Think of it as hell on earth."
Aside from Thailand, "Annihilation" also
shot scenes on location in Israel, Jordan,
and the United Kingdom, with shooting in the
latter location including the abandoned copper
mine Parys Mountain. In a 1997 interview timed
to coincide with the film's release, Kasanoff
explained that wet, windy weather conditions
at the copper mine had hampered filming. In
one instance, the winds picked up so dramatically
that the production's base camp was blown away.
One of the few actors from the 1995
"Mortal Kombat" film to return for
"Annihilation" was Robin Shou, reprising his
fan-favorite role as master martial artist
Liu Kang. While Shou performed
many of his own fight scenes,
he did have a stunt performer double
for certain aspects of his performance.
Doubling for Shou in "Annihilation" was
Thai actor and stunt choreographer Tony Jaa,
who would go on to have his own celebrated
career as a martial arts movie star.
Jaa became known to international audiences after
starring in the 2003 martial arts film "Ong-Bak:
The Thai Warrior," and he's since
gone on to appear in "Furious 7"
and "Monster Hunter." Though Jaa had
done stunt work in local Thai films,
"Annihilation" provided him a major
stepping stone, with Jaa recalling
years later his good fortune in fitting
Shou's physical size and fighting style.
Like Tony Jaa, prolific stunt performer
Ray Park similarly rose from nameless
background performer to beloved genre star
shortly after his work in "Mortal Kombat."
Park had one of his first on-camera experiences
in "Annihilation," and like Perry, he took on
multiple roles to do so. Most notably,
the Scottish stuntman doubled for James
Remar as Raiden in various sequences. Park
also doubled for Dennis Keifer as Baraka,
and appeared as one of the monstrous Outworld
Reptile ninjas that menace the heroes.
Park broke out in 1999, appearing
as both Darth Maul in "Star Wars:
Episode I — The Phantom Menace" and as the
Headless Horseman in Tim Burton's "Sleepy
Hollow." Park's first major on-screen speaking
role was in 2000's "X-Men," playing the acrobatic
mutant supervillain Toad, and he went on to
play Snake Eyes in the early "G.I. Joe" films.
Park has since navigated some controversies,
but during a panel appearance at Salt Lake City
Comic-Con in 2013, he credited "Mortal Kombat:
Annihilation" for jump-starting his career,
and expressed interest in returning
to the franchise if ever invited.
Chris Conrad replaced Linden Ashby in the role
of Johnny Cage in "Annihilation". Audiences
didn't have long to get accustomed to Conrad
in the role, however, as Johnny is brutally
killed by Shao Kahn in the opening scene. As
Conrad recalled to Killerfilm.com in 2011,
"Yep, got my neck broke in record time. I
told people when it came out to 'get your
popcorn and Rasinets after the first
10 minutes, so you don't miss me!'"
But despite this quick, unceremonious
dispatching of the beloved character,
tentative plans at the time were to have Johnny
return later in the film as a ghost. Evidently,
that's not how things played
out in the film's production.
There were plans by Kasanoff
to continue the film series
with a sequel to "Annihilation," tentatively
named "Mortal Kombat: Devastation." However,
the poor critical and commercial reception
of "Annihilation" quietly led to the project
being delayed for years. In the early 2000s
pre-production picked up again, with both
Shou and Ashby saying in interviews at the time
that the film was planning to go into production.
After a planned filming location in
Louisiana was impacted by Hurricane
Katrina and Kasanoff unsuccessfully
sued to stop the sale of Midway Games
and the "Mortal Kombat" license to Warner
Bros., "Devastation" was shelved for good.
Though Kasanoff envisioned "Annihilation"
going bigger and better than its predecessor,
a tight production budget and rushed
schedule complicated matters. This led
to significant sequences that were written
for the film being reduced or cut entirely.
In an interview for "Lights, Camera, Game
Over!", co-writer Brent V. Friedman recalled
that budget limitations lead to major
cuts from the final screenplay, saying,
Looking back on the disastrous critical
reception and box office drop-off for the
"Mortal Kombat" sequel, Kasanoff cites a rushed
production schedule as the primary culprit.
In "Lights, Camera, Game Over!", Kasanoff
said he should have insisted the studio
wait at least six more months before launching
into Annihilation's production. Unfortunately,
the breakneck schedule they opted for resulted
in truncated development and post-production
cycles. It also required additional material
to be filmed to make things more coherent.
Kasanoff revealed that they had no time
for reshoots to resolve any plot holes
if they were to meet the studio's all-important
deadline. Looking back, Kasanoff explained that he
would've liked an additional week in Thailand and
Jordan, along with several weeks of studio time,
to undergo reshoots after reviewing
a rough cut. However, like the issues
with the post-production cycle, these hopes were
dashed in order to reach the unyielding deadline.
The post-production team for "Annihilation" was
spread all over the globe, but despite
the production's global talent reach,
the visual effects were still not completed
in time to meet the studio's release date.
This failure to meet the anticipated deadline
did not deter the studio from proceeding with
the movie's theatrical release, much to
Kasanoff's chagrin. In "Lights, Camera,
Game Over!", Kasanoff admits that the visual
effects in "Annihilation" remain unfinished
to this day, with the studio deeming
them, quote, "good enough" at the time.
"...Pretty cool huh?"
With expectations riding high for
"Annihilation" to meet its November
1997 release date, the studio estimated
the unfinished film would make better
business releasing on time than delaying
the premiere to complete its effects.
Though Lambert did not reprise his role
as Raiden for "Annihilation," the actor
was considered to return to the franchise
for a canceled follow-up. In an August 2016
interview with Loaded, Lambert revealed he had
read a script for a proposed third film and,
in contrast to "Annihilation," he
enjoyed the planned sequel's screenplay,
though it's unclear if the script that Lambert
read was the same one seen by Shou or Ashby.
According to Lambert, the next "Mortal Kombat"
film would've bent the rules of space and time,
with fighters traveling through time to totally
different locations in the midst of battle. The
planned film may have been part of New Line's
attempts to revive the franchise, as a reboot
was announced in 2011 with Kevin Tancharoen
attached to direct. In November 2016, Simon
McQuoid was hired to helm what would eventually
become the 2021 "Mortal Kombat" reboot, discarding
any plans for a sequel to "Annihilation,"
along with Lambert's potential return.
After directing the 1995 "Mortal
Kombat," Paul W.S. Anderson would
go on to helm different video game
film adaptations, including "Resident
Evil" and "Monster Hunter." Anderson was
appalled at how the cinematic world he had
helped introduce in the first "Mortal
Kombat" was diminished by its sequel.
This observation would affect how Anderson
approached his management of the "Resident
Evil" franchise, with the filmmaker
intent on taking a more hands-on role
to ensure a consistent level of quality.
In "Lights, Camera, Game Over!," he shared,
"Mother - you're alive!"
"Too bad YOU… will die!"
Anderson produced and wrote every
installment of the "Resident Evil" series,
and directed four of the movies.
He has credited at least some of
this grand design to the knowledge
of what "Kombat" became, saying,
The original "Mortal Kombat" video game
was created by Ed Boon and John Tobias,
with Boon remaining alongside the franchise
throughout its lengthy history. Boon has
voiced the character Scorpion since the 1991 game,
reprising his voiceover role as the masked ninja
warrior for both the 1995 film and "Annihilation."
Despite voicing the character in "Annihilation,"
Boon regards the 1997 film as the franchise's
lowest point, a stance shared by Tobias.
In a 2012 interview for Complex looking
back on the entire history and legacy of
the "Mortal Kombat" franchise, Boon kept
his analysis succinct, saying he was not a
fan of "Annihilation." Tobias, meanwhile, is
credited as a contributing co-writer to the
story of "Annihilation," along with Kasanoff
and Joshua Wexler. Friedman and Bryce Zabel,
are credited for the screenplay. In an online
Q & A, Tobias similarly listed "Annihilation"
as his least favorite "Mortal Kombat"
memory, and recalled seeing rough cuts
of the film during production that drove
home a sharp drop in cinematic quality.